okay well briefly quickly
lee when you said that time is
fundamental i don't know if you actually
said that but when you you were talking
about entropic time is what we normally
think of as physicists as
as precipitating the arrow of time and
you're saying that well that may be the
wrong way of going about it so are your
views more aligned with lee because lee
believes time to be fundamental
but briefly lee if you don't mind oh
sorry he hasn't lee smalling yeah yeah
sorry yeah yeah well so i first met lee
smolin and i told him my theory thomas
oh that's my theory and i'm like wow our
names are both lee
yeah so i mine is slightly more dramatic
and remember i'm a professional idiot
regis idiot and what i mean by that is
that um i don't get confined by
discipline boundaries so it was when i
first told sarah my theory of time she
was just like this is just can't be true
you know this is just but all i'm saying
is that there is no such thing as space
there is time okay
and from and time creates space right in
some mechanism that we don't really
understand and that um that breaks in
everything we need i tried to argue with
sean carroll about this but he didn't
even argue he said no you're just wrong
i was like why i said well my theory is
better time can go forward and backwards
and i'm like that breaks causality so
time is primal time creates space
and
um and there the the there is a finite
amount of time that has existed in our
current universe right that doesn't mean
there aren't things outside our universe
and uh and it works a bit like that and
that's why assembly
helps us quantify that through assembly
is almost like looks at the degree of
asymmetry since the beginning of time
that's recorded but i can i can budge on
some of it but that's it in two or three
sentences yeah we'll talk about that
we'll perhaps have another podcast and
so people who are watching if you have
questions for brian and or lee leave
them below okay brian do you have any
quick comments on the nature of time
before we get to the questions from the
audience well i think you know time
again is one of these things that you
know we kind of know it when we see it
it's it's like you know what does it
feel like to be a bat you know nagel's
question you know so he's just like we
don't know
and i find that uh sort of interpretable
in the sense of we know it when we feel
it we know it when we see it we have
biological clocks
we're turning grayer and grey kurt
doesn't know that yet but but someday he
will uh we take comfort that his
diminution and beauty will only only
catch up to artists well you look like
buzz lightyear man like that's a huge
compliment someone in the lex comments
said that and i thought man that's
exactly right and you're an astronomer
as well and lee you're a great looking
guy yeah i remember when i saw you i'm
like this is a good looking guy
i don't want to be in the same podcast
you're a good-looking guy too brian yeah
thank you very much but that means he
lives in a bubble you know you're power
more you're a powerful looking guy brian
i'd say that
thank you thank you i do have a strong
aroma well well i'd rather be
okay never mind
so time you know i had talked about this
with frank wilczyk on on my into the
impossible podcast i said what is time
you know just like i asked lee what is
life um yeah i asked other people
helping out philip goff on i'll ask him
what is consciousness you know it's like
we know it when we see it frank said to
me will chuck said you know time is what
clock's mentioned all right thanks a lot
you know yeah but anything could be a
clock so i think what's interesting is
to pursue the path that lee has pursued
uh you know what is the simplest mole
you know chemical that can form
with with inspiration with direction
towards evolutionary purposes and he has
simulations that you can see in his ted
talk about that's brilliant um i think
there's a experiment done at nist and
i'm going to have a nicole halpern
younger on who's a brilliant scientist
at nist in maryland and she has a new
book called quantum steampunk which is
really delightful kind of in the vein of
a roger penrose emperor's new new mind
uh in which she talks about you know
what is the world's simplest clock and
on my channel i make explainer videos
and one i did is what is time and and
how can you understand time um by making
the world's simplest clock and what is
the clock something that ticks okay well
what is something that takes well it has
quantum states and i think the
revolution that uh would be interesting
for another podcast maybe lee and and
kurt will come on my podcast maybe with
avi loeb we can have a knockdown drag
out a conversation lee smallin just get
everybody in there mosh pit uh is to
talk about well what are the quantum
implications you know there's quantum
thermodynamics that's coming to the
front things like sillard entropy and
stuff that lee knows about that i'm just
learning about i think these are all
really fruitful and i wonder how that
could feed into things that lee is
working on but yeah for now maybe um you
want to talk about uh meaning from
science or do you want to talk audience
questions i want to do i want to make
sure that we answer all the audience
yeah let's get to that